>> BEING UNVEILED, THANK YOU,
SOUTH DAKOTA.
SPEAKING OF THAT, LET’S TURN TO
THE WORLD OF SPORTS.
I READ IRVING SPEAKING OUT
WHILE REMAINING SIDELINED FOR
REFUSING THE COVID 19 VACCINE.
THE BROOKLYN NUTS GUARD SAYS IT
IS DREAMWORKS.
HE TWEETED GOD NEVER FAILS, NEW
YORK CITY ABSTRACT VACCINE
MANDATES, IRVING HAS YET TO
SUIT OF THE SEASON
SUIT OF THE SEASON FOR THE
NINTENDO AND CLEAR IF HE WILL
TAKE THE COURT FOR ANY ROAD
GAMES AS MORE AND MORE CITIES
HAVE ASKED REQUIREMENTS.
HERE TO REACT, THE FOUNDER,
CLAY TRAVIS.
>> TENNESSEE GETTING READY FOR
GEORGIA.
YOU CAN SEE THE STADIUM OVER MY
SHOULDER, GOING TO BE AN
AWESOME DAY IN KNOXVILLE.
>> RE-SAYING GOD NEVER FAILS.
YOU WERE TWEETING ABOUT THIS
EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE NBA HAS
A ROLLING VACCINE REQUIREMENT,
IT REQUIRES BOOSTERS AS WELL.
>> THE NBA IS SORT OF GIVING US
A SIGNAL
A SIGNAL OF WHERE MANY
DIFFERENT PLACES ARE GOING.
THEY ARE ENCOURAGING EVERYONE
WHO GOT THE VACCINE TO GET THE
BOOSTER AND FOR THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON VACCINE IF YOU DON’T
GET THE BOOSTER YOU ARE NO
LONGER CONSIDERED VACCINATED.
YOU ARE TALKING MULTIPLE SHOTS,
A ROLLING CONSISTENT NOT ENDING
COVID VACCINE REQUIREMENT AND
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE HOW MANY
SHOTS WILL BE REQUIRED AND HOW
LONG WILL IT GO ON AND I GIVE
CREDIT TO KYLIE IRVING BECAUSE
MANY ATHLETES WANT TO TALK
ABOUT POLITICS BUT MOST OF THEM
DON’T RISK ANYTHING IN THE
PROCESS.
CHI READ IRVING IS WALKING AWAY
FROM TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND IS STANDING FOR
WHAT HE BELIEVES IN AND I GIVE
HIM CREDIT FOR SPEAKING OUT
LIKE I GAVE AARON RODGERS
CREDIT FOR SPEAKING OUT, LIVING
IN AN AUTHENTIC WORLD, HEARING
WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVE EVEN IF YOU
DON’T AGREE WITH THEM
PARTICULARLY AS PERTAINS TO
COVID VACCINE MANDATES, IT IS
AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE THEY ARE
SENDING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
PETE: THE STADIUM IS YOUR
BACKDROP BUT FOR FOX SPORTS,
THE KICKOFF SHOW, YOU’RE IN
KNOXVILLE WERE TENNESSEE IS
TAKING ON GEORGIA, SOMETHING WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT, I
DID A BETTER JOB THAN YOU, TWO
BOYS, SUCCESSFULLY BRAINWASHED
THEM BOTH, YOU HAVE THREE, YOU
ARE SINGLE DAD THIS WEEKEND,
YOU LOST ONE 2 ALABAMA.
>> SUPERTOUGH FOR TENNESSEE
FAN.
ALABAMA DOESN’T LOSE, HASN’T
BEEN IN ALABAMA SINCE NICK
SABIN GOT TO TUSCALOOSA.
THIS IS A FAN VISIT WE CAN,
GIVE GEORGIA A FIGHT HERE.
HERE IS THE TRUTH.
AT LEAST THESE -- HE IS -- AS
OPPOSED TO YOU POSERS.
>> KICK ME WHILE I AM DOWN FOR
FIVE LOSSES.
I TOOK TENNESSEE AND ALMOST 20
POINTS THIS WEEK.
>> Is.
>> WHERE YOU ARE SEEING THESE
GAMES GO, AGAINST BAYLOR, 5 AND
A HALF ON THIS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> OKLAHOMA HAS NOT BEEN
CONSISTENT OF LATE OR EARLY IN
THE SEASON.
QUARTERBACK DRAMA.
I THINK WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, COMING UP A TOUGH LOSS,
THEY KEEP IT CLOSE.
I FEEL LIKE OH YOU FIND A WAY
TO WIN BUT 5 AND A HALF FEEL
STEEP TO ME.
I WILL BE IN THE BIG MAN
KICKOFF GAME, REGGIE BUSH, MATT
LEINART, THEY WILL BE LIVE IN
15 MINUTES FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO GET READY FOR GAME
TIME.
WILL: MARYLAND VERSUS MICHIGAN
STATE.
>> I THINK MICHIGAN STATE
OUNCES BACK.
MARYLAND HAD A TOUGH LOSS
AGAINST PENN STATE, FOLDED
LATE, MICHIGAN WENT ON THE ROAD
AGAINST PURDUE, GAVE UP THE
RECORD BUT THE REALITY FOR
MICHIGAN STATE AS LONG AS THEY
KEEP WINNING THEY WILL BE FINE
BECAUSE THEY CAN WIN THE BIG 10
E. BUT IF THEY WENT OUT THEY
WILL HAVE LESS TO PLAY FOR.
THEY GET BACK IN A GOOD TRENDS,
TAKE CARE OF THE TURFS AND
ROLLED TO A VICTORY.
>> THE COWBOYS, HORNED FROGS,
8:00, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> OKLAHOMA STATE.
THE BIG 12 IS WIDE OPEN EXCEPT
FOR TEXAS WHICH WAS ILLUMINATED
A MONTH AGO BUT THE REST OF THE
TEAM AT THE TOP OF THE BIG 12
HAVE A LOT TO PLAY FOR.
THE SQUAD WANTS TO BE ROLLING
IN WITH A CHANCE TO BE THE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL SEED IN THE
BIG 12 TITLE GAME, NOT
OKLAHOMA.
I THINK THEY ARE ROLLING A
LITTLE BIT.
TCU, GARRETT PATTERSON, THE
COACH, A LITTLE BIT OF A MESS
GOING ON IN THAT SITUATION.
I LIKE OKLAHOMA STATE, THE
COWBOYS GETTING THINGS DONE.
WILL: I WILL TELL THIS MY POINT
WEEKEND.
I’M TAKING ALL THE POINTS.
I LIKE THE POINTS.
YOU LIKE TO PLAY, FOLLOW IT,
DOWNLOAD, YOU CAN PLAY, FOX
BETSY PHYSICS APPS, A CHANCE TO
IN 20,$000 THIS WEEKEND, PICK